-We talked about it
briefly backstage,
but the first film I saw you in
was a wonderful Australian crime
film, "Animal Kingdom."
-Indeed, the series
of the same name is based on it.
-Yeah, and you were very
villainous in that role.
-Yeah, he's not a nice guy.
-He's not a nice guy.
His name is Pope, so I guess...
-Yeah.
-Pope, King -- yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
No gray area on him.
Very much --
Nobody walked out
of that film being like,
"I liked him the most."
-Some did.
But, you know, Australians,
they have peculiar sense
of this stuff.
-Do you still get recognized
from that film?
-Yeah. A bit.
I mean, but they don't
tend to come up to me.
-Yeah.
-So that one it's sort of like,
"Oh, yeah,
they saw 'Animal Kingdom,'"
'cause they just
sort of go away.
You know more if it's
"Bloodline" or "Star Wars."
-And I want to -- It's very nice
to see you in this role,
because you play a nice person.
-Yes.
-It was really lovely
to see you play a nice person.
-Thank you very much.
-And you actually --
Because that was --
For people that don't know,
that was Gary Oldman
as Winston Churchill.
Unrecognizable.
-That is Gary Oldman.
-You look a fair amount
like King George here.
That's not bad.
-Yeah. I think, uh...
I think, you know, Joe --
You know, Joe --
That's why he gave me the job.
-Yeah.
-You look like him.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he was like, look,
"I'm wasting my entire
makeup budget on Gary."
-Yep.
-I need some --
Everybody else has to look
exactly like
who they're playing.
-Yep. That's it.
-Famously, obviously, this is --
You're playing someone
who had a lisp.
You had to use a dialect coach.
-Yep.
-How was that?
Was that intense?
-Yeah, yeah,
it's pretty full on.
Yeah, I mean, the --
It starts to happen.
[ Laughter ]
-Even thinking --
Even saying dialect coach now...
-And once you start
to get close to them,
they start to invade you
at various times.
But, yeah.
It was a lot of work.
"The King's Speech" is the same
character a little earlier on.
A little bit of a worse,
you know, stutter.
-Wow.
So you had to go back.
You had to step back
from even that.
-I had to go forward from that,
yes, to step back from that.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-One of the great things
about the new "Star Wars" films,
so many people were fans
and happy to see them back.
I'm always happy to hear that
the actors who are lucky enough
to be in those films were fans.
You were a fan of "Star Wars"?
-Oh, yeah.
No, I mean,
the first one comes out,
I'm in the cinema,
I'm 8 years old,
and then, "BVVVV!"
the ship comes overhead, I'm in.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-And so was there a moment
on set that you realized,
"Oh, I'm in a 'Star Wars' movie
right now"?
-Yeah, once --
So you do the rehearsals,
and this and that,
and you know
you're gonna be in it,
but, you know --
For those of you
that don't know,
I kind of built the Death Star.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And, um, so...
-And that's great,
because, really, when you think,
King George didn't do
anything close to that.
-Oh, well, you know.
-[ Laughing ]
I mean, yeah.
Different, but when you have
those stormtroopers there,
yeah, you know you're in
a "Star Wars" movie.
-That's really great,
and you had a lot of --
You had just
teams of stormtroopers
behind you in that film.
-I did.
I did, indeed.
-Yeah, congratulations on that.
-Thank you very much.
-First time you saw Darth Vader,
how was that?
-It was -- You know, it was
personal, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you keep -- No,
I genuinely want to ask this.
Did you keep your cool the first
time you saw Darth Vader on set?
-No.
No, not at all.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, not at all.
For a start, he's enormous.
-Yeah.
-He's got
a really bad breathing problem.
I mean, like --
[ Laughter ]
You think George
has got problems speaking?
I mean, it's hard for Darth.
-Yeah.
-But, you know,
I mean you stay there,
you listen, and, in fact,
there kind of are
similarities between King George
and Darth in that way.
-And does Darth show up
for rehearsal and everything?
-No, no, never.
No, no, no.
Darth, I mean --
There's a stand-in guy
that does Darth's stuff.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And then you'd be waiting
around, and it'd be like,
"Okay,
Darth's gonna be here soon."
It's like,
"Darth's going to be here soon,"
and then you hear --
[ Breathing loudly ]
-Is he ever apologetic
about keeping everyone waiting?
-Never apologizes.
Never explains.
That seems to be
one of his things.
-I don't know.
It's just a shame.
-He's that kind of guy,
but, look...
-It's a shame
he doesn't try harder.
the work is wonderful though,
so, you know, whatever.
-I have heard --
We share something else.
We are both comic-book fans.
-Oh, yeah.
-Is that something you were
a fan of your whole life?
-Yeah.
Yes and no.
I mean,
I'm a mild comic-book fan.
I wouldn't want to go toe-to-toe
with a serious one.
-Yeah.
-I'm talking about
the Kirby kind of "X-Men" years.
I'm talking McFarlane's --
-Seth McFarlane, yeah.
"Spider-Man" stuff?
-Exactly, and later, "Spawn."
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-There we go.
We match up very well on that.
-There you go.
-And you mentioned --
You mentioned "Bloodline,"
getting recognized more
for "Bloodline."
Do you find the TV work you do
you get recognized
more for than your --
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Because people spend more time
with you on TV.
I'm in the lounge room,
as it were.
-Yeah.
-You know, whereas
they don't expect
to see someone from "Star Wars"
walking down the street.
You know what I mean?
-That's true.
-There's a bit of a disconnect.
-Yeah, because when you think --
You look more like
your character in "Bloodline"
in real life than you do
in your "Star Wars" character.
-Thank you.
-I think?
-I think, yeah.
-Yeah.
I never thought of it that way,
that you'd be very surprised
to see someone, and you're like,
"When was last time
I saw that guy?"
You'd be like,
"Oh, the Death Star."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It would definitely
take you a minute.
-Yeah, it does.
It takes them a minute, yeah.
-Well, congratulations
on the film.
-Thank you.
-And in general,
just such a delight to meet you.
Thanks so much for being here.